merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse sur
le ministre le 21 septembre dernier dans
le huis clos de son école vide à pantin
une directrice se donner la mort elle
s'appelait christine renom elle avait 58
ans le même jour à nice à son domicile
professeur de biologie disait adieu à la
vie s'appelait frédéric boulet il avait
aussi 58 ans chaque semaine la liste des
fonctionnaires qui se suicident
s'allonge policiers soignants
enseignants parce qu'ils sont à bout
épuisé parce qu'ils se sentent de moins
en moins considéré parce qu'ils sont mal
payés parce qu'ils sont parfois insulter
agresser parce qu'ils sont stigmatisés
alors qu'ils sont tout sauf des
privilégiés comme nos amis agriculteurs
si chaque suicide garde une part de
mystère
christine renom n'est pas parti dans le
silence laissant une lettre à ses
collègues un appel à ouvrir les yeux
je n'en dirai qu'une phrase je dois dire
aussi que je n'ai pas confiance au
soutien et à la protection que devrait
nous apporter notre institution depuis
des années dans l'éducation nationale
les réformes se succèdent s'accumulent
pourtant le malaise persiste et même en
pire la confiance dont parlait christine
renom et qui ornait le titre de votre
loi est rompu je sais votre attachement
aux professeurs mais que répondez vous à
ces directeurs et enseignants en
souffrance se plaignant de ne pas être
écoutés de voir toutes ces réformes
élaborées sans leur accord tandis que
l'école est le réceptacle de tous les
maux de la société